hang is writing in Ivan and Steven I
don't know what I want
I feel impertinent how do I find myself
in my dream I think you gotta think
about what I love doing what I really
get excited about what am i passionate
you know what is it I could do where we
could create some value in a business
that means we can materially improve the
well-being of our consumers business
customers or whatever the community the
try said that that's kind of the key
thing if you don't know that test drive
try a few things
try try stuff that you know you really
believe in and you could become
passionate about and see if you come
absolutely overwhelmed and you find them
these are these are the things to strike
up a true mojo if they are then thought
so I think with this sort of thing
think about it sit back reflect asking
buddies find stuff you really love try
some stuff test drive some stuff and if
it's work and do more with on the gas if
it's not kind of reflect again think
about what is it passionate I totally
agree I think if you don't know what you
want to do you have to just explore
just say yes the things start exploring
see what makes you come alive and
whatever you feel excited about just do
more of that and don't put this huge
expectation like this has to be my next
big thing because you're setting
yourself up for failure just go try a
bunch of things see what you love see
what excites you and then take that the
next step in the next step and you'll
find that you follow a certain path and
if you put too much pressure on yourself
and you probably well won't get there